there's all these amazing missions that
have to happen and I'm curious as to how
do we how do we you you were giving any
sources for the ways that we can
potentially get decreased the cost of
the missions increased funding for a
privatized as well it's like and there's
you know the the book about you know
Astrophysical people in a hurry for with
Neil and you know your book the earth in
human hands these books have slowly been
inspiring more people to look up go get
out of the light pollution be like what
it would exists out there how can we get
inspired by the cosmos the all these
stories that you know so the Shaw stack
and I have talked about when you're
looking a kid when they're six or eight
or ten years old looks at the rings of
Saturn through a telescope and it's game
over then they're they're sold on the
beauty of the cosmos forever how how do
we get to getting all these missions to
happen and you might think about the
expansion of the minds of all the young
kids and where they'll lead us to well
you know I think that these things to
feed on themselves I mean Alan and I
when we were kids we watched Apollo and
watch the first five bus - you know Mars
and Jupiter and Saturn and we were like
they want to do more of that you know
now kids are watching new Horizons and
it's like their Apollo
people have taught us that yeah you know
and and hopefully I'm chasing new
horizons we've told the story in a way
that will inspire people and shown you
know sort of how it works and how you
can solve there's a lot of problems to
solve some of them are human and
political some other more technical but
you know where there's a will there's a
way and and you know Alan and his
colleagues they decided they wanted to
do this and they found a way to do it
and I think that kids young people will
be inspired to realize that you know
it's impossible to achieve things that
people are telling you may not be
possible if you if you just get
determined and stick to it you know it's
definitely one of the lessons here yeah
you know that story repeats itself you
know Columbus was told they don't sail
west you'll fall off the edge you know
that there's there's nothing over there
you know and the Wright brothers were
told you know you'll never mastered you
can't do flight you know it's for
balloons and gliders but there's no such
thing as powered flight right and
in the 40s they were saying that rockets
wouldn't work in space because there's
nothing to push against in the vacuum
right and human beings are just amazing
you know we're inquisitive and we're in
a chirally explorers and we're very
ingenious as a species and we make we
make stuff happen and this is really a
story about teamwork too I mean in an
individual human cannot do something
like this
Allen talks about that you know
spaceflight is not something one person
can achieve it's a team sport and this
story of New Horizons a test testament
to that you know at one point there were
2,500 people working on the project
including you know building the rocket
and everything and then it was a much
smaller team that was involved you know
like 50 people that were flying it
across the solar system but it's a team
you know and this is about what human
beings can do when they get together and
organize themselves and and focus on a
long-term goal that that's important to
them you know